michel galabru bonsoir et bonne année et
bonne année si on m'avait dit qu'un jour
je souhaiterais une bonne année 2010 à
michel galabru alors
ça part bien 2012 un galabru invité
d'honneur de salut les terriens stone et
charden comme la légion d'honneur un
film dans le nord de cloclo ses boules
21e siècle
voilà l'émission s'appelle salut les
terriens et le coup
alors michel galabru re bonsoir j'ai
fait le compte cette année en france on
a pu vous voir dans 35 rediffusion de
films c'est pas possible
ce soir vous êtes vraiment là où c'est
qu'une rediffusion n'a
alors vous êtes ici ce soir en vrai pour
nous parler de la pièce que vous allez
jouer à partir du 10 janvier au théâtre
hébertot dans une mise en scène d'alain
saxe la femme du boulanger de marcel
pagnol à presque 90 ans à vos avis gamme
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
alors l'histoire on la connaît dans un
village de haute provence un boulanger
récemment installé découvre un matin que
sa jeune épouse est partie avec un
verger et ils décident de faire la grève
du pain tant qu'on la retrouvera pas
alors tout le village se mobilise
évidemment pour retrouver la femme du
boulanger bah oui c'est une histoire
éternelle c'est à dire que la jeune
femme quitte peu vieux berquin
c'est un lâchage alors à l'époque le
pain était beaucoup plus apporte quand
même et donc il fait la grève de pabu de
la fin mai de la date du pain du pain
voilà et l'hiver dernier
la pièce a été donné en direct sur
france 2 c'était un triomphe
4,6 millions de téléspectateurs c'est
énorme enfin bon ça fait 4 bio 6 1 6 3
qui viendra pas peut-être voir la pièce
puisqu'ils l'ont déjà vu ça de l'autre
côté stembert dont
vous êtes prêts là pour la pièce cela on
n'est jamais prêt parce qu'on a peur a
toujours vous savez cette peur qui
accompagne l'acteur jusqu'à la fin ce
dernier claf loi clap de fin on va tout
jouer longtemps comme ça sur scène mais
vous savez on dit toujours ça un vieux
bonhomme est bien là vous arrêtez pas
est ce que vous allez dire un type qui
dit jour bridge vous arrêté le 4 un
pêcheur vous arrêtez de piché un pet
j'ai arrêté de peindre l écrivain des
trucs à vous arrêter de chasser la botte
notari peut pas encore peu voilà il faut
voilà et la bonne vous chasser plus la
bonne quand même
non hélas ces philippins la plus droite
[Applaudissements]
alors vous avez publié récemment une
autobiographie intitulée je ne sais pas
dire non vous savez que c'est exactement
le titre de l'autobiographie de clara
morgane quand même
ah merde alors dans votre autobiographie
on apprend que vous êtes né au maroc à
sa fille votre père était ingénieur des
ponts et chaussées et ils participaient
à la construction du port de la ville
vous dites quand vous parlez de cette
époque 80 des lis ça j'ai compris après
vous savez quand il ya eu ce drame pour
les pieds noirs comme un levier d'abord
donné j'ai compris que leur leur leur
leurs peines leurs mails au stade j
parce que ce sont des pays d'afrique du
nord vers veilleuse à ce que via une
insouciance la baisse que c'est dû au
soleil je ne sais pas il ya une joie de
vivre je ne sais pas comment expliquer
ce à quoi et toute votre vie vous avez
regretté en fait ces huit premières
années oui le garçon qui s'occupait de
vous s'appelait mahdjoub un jour oui
c'était un noir et j'ai gardé une
tendresse pour lui juste je suis allé le
revoir ce sont les revoir au maroc oui
on m'a dit l'habite la maintenant dans
la campagne entre safi et marrakech et
et là j'ai vu une petite jeune fille qui
gardait des vaches j'ai dit je voudrais
voir monsieur mahjoub allait elle est
partie en courant j'ai cru que j'allais
lui a fait peur et les revenus avec une
jeune femme encore jeune et d'arabes
blanche j'ai du jeu je suis monsieur
vient la brute et quarante ans après il
m'a dit oui michel extraordinaire elle
était jeune parce que là bas il avait
épousé à 12 ans voix oui c'est ce que
pas permis ici bien en 1930 notre père
est muté en métropole dont vous vous
retrouvez au havre et vous dites je suis
resté quatre ans dans cet enfer je
venais du soleil je veux tu avais pas
l'école l'arbre futur lycée n était pas
pire que pire pires pulsions mais
j'étais malheureux parce fait oui alors
ensuite vos parents partent à madagascar
et vous est envoyé dans une pension
catholique à montpellier à l'école vous
est le cancre absolu vous êtes exclu de
cette pensionnat play et à l'époque en
fait vous rêvez d'être joueur de foot
oui vous prenez pour un titre que vous
inventez que sa femme michèle seiler
vous êtes là vous tous que vous êtes
tous invités michel jallet reprend la
balle michel dallaire 16 décembre c'est
à dire tri s'il fait des ravages à
placer leurs maris grand footballeur
ouais ouais mais en fait la vraie
passion qui l'emportera c'est le théâtre
mais quand vous découvrez sacha guitry
voilà je deviens michel libri michel
livre y voit toujours zeller c'était
parce qu'il y avait des des joueurs
autrichiens hongrois dans l'équipe de
montpellier 1 et y avait du coeur il y
avait un air de les payer non ça me
plaisait et guitry ses livres il ya une
espèce d'identification vous parler
comme lui vous habillez vous avez acheté
des bagues voir mardi gbagbo il avait
deux bagues bon c'était pas payer les
bacs qu'il avait c'était à monoprix à
vingt balles ça d'été diester dégage en
fait vous n'avez jamais été vous-même en
fait voilà voilà c'est ça l'histoire
c'est ça c'est ça qui est très curieux
alors vous êtes en philo en 1940 quand
le grand résistant jean françois devait
le fondateur de minutes vous propose de
vous battre avec lui dans le maquis
contre les nazis et vous refusez je dois
dire que j'ai manqué de courage ce qui
fait que je suis là aujourd'hui espace a
toujours eu davantage la lâcheté alors
moi je dis ah oui je veux bien mais je
viens ce qu'il faudra se battre hamdi
oui à j'ai dit je vais réfléchir
une opinion comme une autre mais ouais
ben ari pareillement alors en revanche
dénoncé envoyé au service du travail
obligatoire en autriche en yougoslavie
il veut ça viry alors après la guerre
contre l'avis de votre père qui veut
vous fassiez du droit il vous dit si tu
fais ton droit je te ferait entrer au
contentieux se borne pas real sans filet
d'air en plus contentieux dont vous
mentez à paris pour préparer le
conservatoire est là pour bouffer vous
êtes des marcheurs vous vendez des
assurances incendie n'est pas facile non
c'est pas facile surtout pour moi
j'habite gueule d'assassins d'époque et
les gens avaient peur quand ils
vouvoyaient
je n'ai pas placé beaucoup alors vous
avez quand même le premier prix de
comédie classique et moderne au
conservatoire et vous entré à la comédie
française à l'âge de 28 ans mais quand
même très très bien mais ça vous plaît
pas à quoi il ya beaucoup d'intrigués
vous êtes parti en claquant la porte en
plus à l'époque vous voyez philippe
noiret michel serrault qu'il y avait
tout ça qui est bien et moi j'étais là
ne rien faire ou alors voilà alors après
votre filmographie sera comme on peut
dire un régime légal
vous pouvez tous joué le problème c'est
que justement vous l'avez fait
alors vous avez fait deux cent soixante
films arp réussite est là dans l'ordre
non c'est à dire que j'ai fait c'est
fait et 260 fils j'ai fait surtout des
deux jours oui oui ces deux jours der
jour bien de matinée donc ça fait j'ai
fait peut-être quel film on avait un
rôle un peu importants donc mettons que
j'ai fait 210 x 2 jours voilà tout ça
fait quatre cent vingt jours voilà
soixante ans c'est rien alors votre
frère vous a dit un jour quand je vois
ton nom à la fiche d'un film je sais
qu'il faut pas y aller quoi
alors la question que tout le monde se
pose michel lepire c'est lequel aa
c'est difficile à prouver parce que il y
en a eu des gratiné le problème c'est
qu'à l'époque j'avais des problèmes
d'argent et que vous préfériez lire le
chèque que le scénario quoi écoutez je
fais des mauvais films je suis pas le
seul on savait par avec poiret et
serrault pendant près de 20 ans dans son
livre cité quoi la raison c'était que
votre première femme vous coûter cher
c'est saint michel non je peux pas dire
ça n'est ce pas quoique quoique les je
ne dirais pas qu'il ya prescription
maintenant prescription oui m'enfin
quand même comme une écoute et quelle
voix sur votre émission je verrai
kananga de mariée coûté voilà si vous ne
regardez
[Applaudissements]
voilà et puis et puis en 1964 vous êtes
à saint tropez et vous entendez cette
phrase pour le rôle principal je veux
louis de funès et pour les autres vous
me mettrez 5 ringard voilà c'était deux
gendarmes à saint tropez voilà
filmdeculte si vous avec personne ne
pouvait soupçonner c'était destiné non
vous pouvez me faire un cruchot là à me
faire plaisir non cruchot voilà
[Applaudissements]
je suis content alors le miracle
arrivera en 1976 les 54 ans et là vous
tournez le juge et l'assassin de
bertrand tavernier qui vous vaudra un
césar du meilleur acteur face à deux
longs de verre et depardieu et puis
ensuite la main tout un tas de films qui
sont bien il ya uranus de berry il ya le
mordant denman il ya les fils rouges de
motivation est là comme quelqu'un de
toujours parler des mêmes et au théâtre
vous attendrez 85 ans pour avoir un
molière c'est incroyable moi je crois
que c'est dû à l'âge oui quand vous
arrivez à certaines âge quand on se sent
que vous avez glissé doucement
il semble que comme une espèce de besoin
de vous donner encore quelques médailles
repartir aujourd'hui attire la donne
tiens il ya ce conte qui va disparaître
faudrait peut-être du fait de lui à
doucier je crois que ça en dit toujours
qu un césar d'honneur ça sent que ça
paraît évident de sa dette michel alors
votre biographie s'appelle je ne sais
pas dire non mais je peux vous embrasser
sur la bouche ah non quand même là dans
la même pas non là il ya des limites
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu